In the following quizzes we'll really be
putting our new knowledge of while-loops,
functions, string slicing, and
if-else statements to the test.
At the end of this work session
you'll be asked to write code for
a function called process_madlib
which takes in a string mad_lib and
returns a new string processed for
all instances of NOUN and VERB,
are replaced with random nouns and
verbs.
This might seem like
a pretty daunting task, and
it's totally normal to have that
feeling of where do I begin?
But the important thing to do before we
start writing any code is to make a plan
to solve this problem.
Now, there are many ways that
we can write this function and
I encourage you to try and
implement your own way, but
I'll show you the way that
I approach this problem.
How about we start with an example?
Let's have this string sentence
was passed into our
process_madlib function.
Let's remember the goal
of our final function.
We're supposed to return a new string
processed where each instance of NOUN or
VERB is replaced with a random noun or
verb.
So let's write our currently empty
string processed right underneath.
Now, the most intuitive approach for me
was to look at each word in the string
past in, check if the word
is equal to NOUN or VERB.
And if it is, we'll add a random noun or
verb to the string processed.
If not, we'll add the word we're
looking at to processed instead.
Although this way of building a Mad Libs
generator seems straightforward,
things can change quite
a bit once you start coding.
For example, when I try putting these
steps into Python, it wasn't so
easy to do.
My code started to become pretty messy.
And as I found,
messy code means buggy code.
Something that I wish I had learned
when I first started programming,
was that if a solution you're working
on just doesn't seem to be working or
is getting too complicated.
Then it can be a good idea
to try a different approach.
It's all right to say all right
this didn't work out too well,
how about we try something different.
So that's what I did,
I stepped back, thought for
a bit,
played a game of ping pong or two,
talked about ways to solve this problem
with some friends, and soon afterwards I
thought of another solution to this
problem that I was excited to try out.
Here's my new approach to the problem.
How about instead of going through
the string passed in word by word,
you go through it
character by character.
Now, imagine if you have a box
that's four characters long.
Once that we place it on top
of the string parsing, so
in this case, sentence.
You then check whatever is inside
this box is equal to NOUN or VERB.
And if it is, we add a random noun or
verb to a processed string, and
move the box over by four characters.
If whatever's inside isn't equal to NOUN
or VERB, we'll just simply add the first
character to our string processed, and
move the box over by one character.
So in this example, everything in
the box is equal to I single space am.
So we ask the question, is the contents
of this box equal to NOUN or VERB?
It's not, so add the first character,
which in this case,
is I, to our processed string,
and move the box over by one.
Now the box is equal to single
space am and single space.
So we ask the same question,
is the box equal to NOUN or VERB?
It's not, so we'll just add the first
character, which is the single space
character to our string processed
and move the box over by one.
Now the box is equal
to am single space a.
So, we ask the same question is box
equal to NOUN or VERB, it's not.
So we'll add the first character,
which in this case is a,
to our processed string.
And move the box over by one.
Let's see if we can
continue this process and
we're almost at the end of our string.
And box is now equal to space NOU.
We ask the same question, is
the box equal to NOUN or VERB?
Well almost but not quite.
So we'll add the first character of
our box, which is a single space,
to our processed string and
move the box over by one character.
Now our box is equal to NOUN.
So we add a random noun to our processed
string and move our box over by four.
And now,
our box is at the end of this sentence.
So we have nothing else to do.
After testing the box idea on
a few other strings with success,
I figure that this was a solid approach
to building a Mab Libs generator.
Since the solution was straightforward,
I transferred over the code pretty well.
Now that we have a good
visual idea of how
the final function is suppose to work.
It's your job to put this in code.